what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we have the Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania trailer let's
not waste any time let's just jump right
into it because I am super excited to
see it
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott ex-con
how are you an Avenger the play of this
injury
everywhere I go people tell me the same
thing thank you
[Music]
oh people still need help though thank
you Spiderman
wait wait a minute you're sending a
signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
they're gonna get sucked in this is
mostly the trailer shown at d23 and sdcc
[Music]
and then okay to go I'll go in at
different times
show us King
give us the Avenger line
Epic
oh he's with her
yo look at that
[Music]
it's beneath ours
yo
here he comes
whoa it isn't what you think oh
yo
Bill Murray
and give you more time
whoa if you help me gang
so
What's it gonna be
happy
oh and he called them by name that's
funny
oh I like that logo change oh we didn't
get the
about you're an Avenger have I killed
you before ah
but as far as trailers go it's pretty
epic they did a good job at teasing Kang
they could they did a good job at
basically like teasing everything they
didn't give us too much they did chose
Bill Murray they did show us a lot of
different new Quantum characters in
there some very different characters
than we've ever seen before I'm gonna be
really really excited to dive into this
shot by shot which I'm about to do now
just wanted to get my reaction out there
and I want to know what everybody else
thinks about this trailer king I think
looks awesome I'm really pumped for
Jonathan Majors to play can't a true
came to conquer not he he will not he
who remains but a true king the
Conqueror I'm really excited for this
suit looks great it looks great and it's
funny how he still kind of is actually
blue when he is wearing the helmet
it's kind of cool how they they actually
did make a very comic accurate suit here
yeah he looks fantastic I'm really
excited for that but hey let me know
what you think about this trailer in the
comments down below who's excited for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania I am
let me know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe stay up to date and
expect a breakdown of this trailer
coming soon I'm working on it right now
I will catch you all next time wolf